[Music]
I'm Kelly Buffet I have two mixed-race
children half Irish and half black my
name is Kathy Weiss and I have a 34 year
old daughter and a 27 year old son
Jeremy who is adopted my name is Shelly
Patrick and I'm the mother of two sons
they're my biological children my name
is Frankie Eddie and I have two children
a six and a half year old daughter named
Lucy and a three and a half year old
adopted son named Joseph my husband and
I started dating when we were in our 30s
and we never really thought about the
fact that we were a mixed-race couple
until we decided to have children my
kids were gonna face situations that I
just didn't know how to navigate because
I had never faced them myself
I remember just sobbing and my husband
taking me in his arms and telling me
that it's not my job to teach my son to
be a black man that it's his job that
it's my job to teach my kids respect and
kindness just like every other mother in
the world regardless of what color my
skin is we tried to have another child
there were issues with me that was not
going to enable us to have another
biological child social workers actually
came out with a policy against
transracial adoptions there was a strong
belief that white families couldn't
provide what black children needed for
their own identity we did not live the
black experience in America and how do
we provide him some connection to what
the world sees him as even if his
personal experience is slightly
different than that we wanted to adopt
for many reasons
my wife was very much compelled she has
an adopted brother and that she worked
at a non-profit that worked with a lot
of former foster youth talked about
trying to have a biological child first
and then the next thing we were
interested in doing is adopting I was
talking to a woman I met at a theater
opening she's african-american the
subject of my kids came up because I
love talking about them she asked
point-blank which is a really good
question are you going to allow some
influence in his life from
african-american people I was kind of
stumped for a second and then realized I
absolutely have to I was only about 20
when I had Jason I don't know if it was
my immaturity but I didn't really look
at my kids as black or white or half I
just looked at them as my children when
I was going through my divorce I'm
seeing a therapist at the time she
pointed out how important it was for the
children to have regular time with their
father and his side of the family so
that they could learn the nonverbal
communication skills of the black
culture so that was something I was
always mindful of and made sure that
that happened consultation is just an
admission that you don't know everything
it doesn't make me feel weird at all it
makes me a little sad to think that he's
going to have some experiences that I
can't entirely relate to my daughter's
hair was definitely a learning
experience I have a niece who also has a
mixed-race daughter she actually has
given me so much information YouTube
tutorials Pinterest learning what
co-washing is just making her realize
how precious and amazing her hair is I
don't think we would have thought about
moving out of Philadelphia for a minute
Jeremy wouldn't feel out of place
growing up he would see other people
that looked like him family friends and
personal friends and teachers you know
we were always aware of that strong
presence in his life he would have the
resources he would go somewhere if he
needed to figure things out
my husband has had to teach me I have
taken on his thoughts on this that you
would rather know who's a racist because
now you know who to stay away from
it's the ones who aren't saying it but
are thinking it are the ones that are
the real issues when Jeremy was a very
young child strangers would come up to
us and say oh he's gonna be a great
ballplayer isn't he at some point I
would say why because he's black at
other points I just got fed up with it
and said no he said
gonna be a brain surgeon it is stunning
to me what comes out of people's mouths
and I am still not quiet about it
I recall this one time I went to look at
a townhouse when I went in to view it
with the realtor a person who lived
there came in and he was like saying oh
this is a great complex and you like
living here and we don't have any and he
used the n-word that live here I'm gonna
get choked up and I said well I will not
be running here because I have two half
black children and it would make me
nervous to have them here with somebody
that thinks that way some white people
just let it roll off when you have
children that you don't just let it
slide you teach your kids tact and you
teach your kids that ignorant is
everywhere unfortunately I'm not going
to be able to save them from everything
it has been very important for me to
talk to Jeremy he had one incident where
somebody said something to him I think
when he was around 11 or 12 and he never
told us and dealt with it probably by
talking to his friends I felt like I had
failed him his friends maybe were a
better resource I felt like why can't he
talk to me about this you have to teach
and you have to talk to your kids about
police brutality you have to talk to
your kids about racist undertones I
would rather have the conversation
before anybody else has it with her so
that she understands where we stand the
interesting thing that I think I've
observed about race I have a privilege
to not be cognizant of it and others do
not I have to be empathetic to my son in
that regard the issues that Joseph may
face terrifies me someday I'm
have to have a real tough conversation
now I just want him to be like the
happiest three and a half year old kid
out there my husband being the black
parent he had talks with them but a few
times when they came home and told me
they had been called a racial name it
really upset me but then when they told
me how they handled it I was so proud of
them I knew that they were equipped and
strong to handle it Jeremy definitely
had identity issues I don't think it was
all smooth sailing and everything's been
you know Leave It to Beaver nice for him
he had to figure out what it meant to be
a black man in America with a white
family and a Jewish background because
he walks into a room and the narrative
is written
he's always struggling with his own
definition against a public definition
is of him so my hope for the future is
that you know we start to evolve as a
nation when you see children playing
together they may be cognizant of the
difference in the way that they look but
there isn't I don't think there is any
preconceived notion I think that racism
is a learned behavior my hope for my
children is that they grow up and they
learn to be kind and they learn to be
respectful Jeremy's trying to make it in
the world of music right now I think he
has great talent but I am a party of one
with a little bit of bias I just want
them to feel safe and feel loved and
secure and who they are I hope that my
children are successful and enjoy their
lives to have fun
[Music]